[Music]
blackbeard captain kidd
the gentleman pirate well the first two
are like very very talented pirates
but the last one is the scariest of them
all instead of killing with weapons he
kills with
kindness
oh right so you're the gentleman pirate
then well sussed
the rumor is you up ended your entire
comfortable life
become a pirate
i got bad news for you genital pirate
pirating is not for everyone
it's a really dangerous lifestyle
love everyone on blackbeard huge fan sir
huge
we're gonna go on up there and
we're gonna cause some havoc how violent
do we expect this to get
the bastard
why'd you
i'm just looting this library when i'm
replacing all the books i've looted with
ones i've already read
you know how hard it is to find someone
doing something original out here
do these outfits maybe feel like an
error in judgment it's a power move make
people feel underdressed and suddenly
you're the one in charge you're a
lunatic
oh we're swashback we're looting
let's have fun with it
[Applause]
come on
give a man a warning that was your
warning
a lot of the guys are sweethearts deep
down oh it's perfect they're just
dealing with a fair amount of trauma
permission to blow them to hell captain
and we're quite certain that pirates
hard to say
one appears to be a heavy set woman in a
silk dressing gown everybody hide
a gentleman never arrives empty-handed i
made tapa
little plates
yeah i know about tapas
[Music]
bye